-Performing "Shotgun"
from her upcoming album,
"Sometimes, Forever,"
please welcome Soccer Mommy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Fogged up the windows
in the back ♪
♪♪
♪ Coffee and menthol
on your breath ♪
♪♪
♪ Uppers and my heart
never meshed ♪
♪ I hated coming down ♪
♪ This feels the same
without the bad things ♪
♪ So whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Cold beer and ice cream
is all we keep ♪
♪♪
♪ The only things
we really need ♪
♪♪
♪ 'Cause I like dessert
and alcohol ♪
♪ And watching as you get ♪
♪ Drunk and you're stumbling
in the hall ♪
♪ So whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Look at your blue eyes
like the stars ♪
♪♪
♪ Stuck in the headlights
of a car ♪
♪♪
♪ You know I'll take you
as you are ♪
♪♪
♪ As long as you do me ♪
♪ So just let me lay here
in your arms ♪
♪ And whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Whenever you want me,
I'll be around ♪
♪ I'm a bullet in a shotgun
waiting to sound ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]